everything is on the move
the sights and sounds of an exodus
they've been told to leave but barely
any time to look back
the water levels Rose dramatically here
in Saffron overnight
[Music]
all they can do is try to strengthen
their defenses now
it may be futile if Beach occurs over
here so hold seven City
it will be down so the situation is
tough we are trying to contain it we're
fighting since last 48 hours
no matter how you frame the cause of
this flood it's a disaster and the poor
are seeing it from every angle
they've had to come up with their own
exit strategy we're on our way to joehi
a city of 300 000 people now an island
only accessible by boat
everywhere around me a house is
completely submerged and we're going to
be going through some pretty difficult
horses
with no roads in or out this is now a
frenetic Waterway for supplies and
safety
and they're carrying everything they can
on board
as we Edge closer it looks like a
bustling Port brimming with energy but
inside the situation is desperate
the water is closing in on them and they
look bewildered
they know they need to move fast
real Hive of activity across
a condo with food whatever they can get
their hands on there's a real sense of
urgency now they're trying to evacuate
as quick as they can
[Music]
but it's 40 degrees and they feel
exposed some by their own government I
think the government should take action
to help our peoples because our people
didn't know about anything they they
haven't any source of resources
even they haven't any food to eat
medicine there is no Transportation you
will see that these are boats are going
away and there are people who give their
own money
they earn little they give lot
that's why we feel very victimized here
they are at the mercy of climate change
there's no quick fix for that all for
these floods and they'll be feeling the
effects for a long time to come Cordelia
lamp Sky News Joe hick Pakistan